The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: in the last
lecture, we discussed
sinusoidal and real and complex
exponential signals
both for continuous time
and discrete time.
And those signals will form very
important building blocks
when we return to a discussion
of Fourier
analysis in a later lecture.
In today's lecture, I'd like to
introduce some additional
basic signals, specifically
the unit step and
unit impulse signal.
Let's begin with discrete time
and the discrete-time unit
step and unit impulse.
The discrete-time unit step is
a sequence as I've indicated
here, specifically a sequence
which is 0 for negative values
of its argument, and equal to
1 for positive values of its
argument and 0.
So mathematically, the unit
step sequence is 1 for n
greater than or equal to 0
and 0 for n less than 0.
The unit impulse sequence,
likewise, is defined in a
straightforward way.
The unit impulse sequence is a
sequence which is 0 for all
values of its argument
except for n = 0.
So the unit step and unit
impulse sequence are defined
in a straightforward
way mathematically.
And in fact, they are also
related to each other in a
straightforward way
mathematically.
Specifically, the unit impulse
can be related to the unit
step through the relationship
that I've indicated here--
delta of n, the unit impulse,
equal to a unit step minus the
unit step delayed.
So mathematically, the
relationship is what is
referred to as a first
difference.
And to see the validity of this
expression, we can simply
look at the unit step and
its delayed version.
So here, we show the
unit step, u[n].
Here, we show the unit
step delayed by 1.
So it's 0 for n less
than or equal to 0.
And clearly, if we subtract
the delayed step from the
original unit step, everything
subtracts out except at n = 0,
at which point the difference
is equal to 1.
And so the difference
between u[n]
and u[n-1]
is simply the unit impulse,
sometimes incidentally also
referred to as the
unit sample.
Now, in a similar way, we can
express the unit step in terms
of the unit impulse.
And there are several
ways of doing this.
One way is through a
relationship referred to as a
running sum.
What I mean by that is the
following expression.
If we think of forming the sum
from minus infinity up to some
value n of a unit impulse or
unit sample, then this running
sum, in fact, is equal
to the unit step.
And we can see that in a fairly
straightforward way, by
simply observing that in this
expression, when n is less
than 0, there's nothing
accumulated in the sum.
And we can see that graphically
as I've shown here.
So for n less than 0,
so we accumulate no
terms in the sum.
Whereas for n greater than 0, we
accumulate 1 non-zero value
in the sum, namely the value of
the unit sample at n = 0.
So we have, then, one
expression for the
relationship between the unit
step and the unit sample.
We can also develop another
relationship by observing in
essence that if we look at the
unit step sequence, as I've
returned to here, we can, in
effect, think of the unit step
sequence as a succession
of unit impulses,
one following another.
So if we consider forming a sum
of delayed impulses, as I
indicate mathematically here,
and as I indicate graphically
down below, we have an impulse
here at n = 0 and an impulse
here at n = 1, an impulse here
at n = 2, et cetera.
And when we continue to add
these up, then what they add
up to is the unit
step sequence.
And so mathematically, then,
that would correspond to an
impulse at n = 0 plus an impulse
at n = 1 plus an
impulse at n = 2, et cetera.
Now, in continuous time, we
have a very more or less
similar situation.
We will find it equally useful
to talk about a unit step
continuous-time signal
and a unit impulse
continuous-time signal.
Let's begin with the
continuous-time unit step.
The continuous-time unit step
function is graphically
indicated as I've shown here.
It's a time function which
is 0 for t less than 0.
And it's 1 for t
greater than 0.
And so mathematically, what
it corresponds to is u[t]
t defined as a time function
which is 0 for t less than 0,
1 for t greater than 0.
Now, an obvious question is,
what happens at t = 0?
And the difficulty here-- which
is not a difficulty that
arises in the discrete-time
case--
is that at t = 0, the units
step function is in fact
discontinuous, which generates
a variety of
mathematical problems.
And one can define the unit step
at t = 0 in a variety of
ways, but the essential point is
that the unit step function
is discontinuous.
So in effect, what we need to
do is think of the unit step
function as the limit of
a continuous function.
And so we can define a function,
which I specify here
as u_delta(t) (u sub
delta of t).
And u_delta(t) is a time
function which is 0 for t less
than 0, linearly increases
to time delta which would
correspond to this
break point, and
then 1 following that.
And so we can think then of the
discontinuous unit step as
the limiting form of u_delta(t)
as delta goes to 0.
Now, we also want to define
a unit impulse function.
And it had a fairly
straightforward definition in
discrete time.
In continuous time, things get
slightly more difficult.
And to motivate the definition,
let me return to
the discrete-time definition--
or rather, the discrete-time
relationship between the unit
step and the unit impulse
function.
In discrete time, we saw that
the unit impulse function is
the first difference of the
unit step function.
Well, similarly in continuous
time, we can talk about an
impulse function, which is the
first derivative of a unit
step function.
So the unit impulse, as we
want to define it, is the
derivative of the unit step.
Of course, we just finished
discussing the fact that the
unit step function is, in fact,
discontinuous at t = 0.
But we can think of its
derivative as related to this
approximation to
the unit step.
And specifically, we will think
of the continuous-time
impulse as the derivative of
u_delta(t) as delta goes to 0.
So to define the unit impulse,
we think of the derivative of
this approximation to the unit
step and then observe what
happens as delta goes to 0.
We have, then, the definition
of the unit impulse function
more or less formally defined as
the first derivative of the
unit step, or thought of as
the limiting form of the
derivative of the approximation
to the unit step
in the limit, as delta,
the duration of the
discontinuity, goes to 0.
Well, let's look at that.
If we think about the derivative
of u_delta(t), the
derivative, of course, is
0 for t less than 0.
It's equal to a constant during
this linear slope, and
then, it's 0 for t greater
than delta.
So the derivative of u_delta(t)
will then be as
I've indicated here.
And it's simply a rectangle with
a height, which is 1 /
delta, and a width, which
is equal to delta.
And observe that no matter what
the value of delta is,
the area is always equal to 1.
Now, as we let delta go to 0,
what happens is that the width
of the rectangle gets smaller,
the height of the rectangle
gets bigger, the area
still remains 1.
As delta goes to 0, of course,
the width goes to 0, and the
height goes to infinity.
And graphically, we choose to
depict that as an arrow, where
the arrow indicates the fact
that we have an impulse
occurring at t = 0, and the
height of the impulse is used
to represent what the area
of the impulse is.
And in this case, since we took
the derivative of a unit
step, the height
is equal to 1.
So the impulse has 0 width,
infinite height, area 1.
It's mathematically not terribly
comfortable because
what we've done is taken the
derivative of the unit step,
which has a discontinuity at the
origin, and there's some
mathematical difficulties
in doing that.
We'll in fact return to another
interpretation of the
impulse later to emphasize some
of the discomfort with
the impulse.
I remember something that Sam
Mason used to say that his
students said about
the unit impulse.
His definition was the unit
impulse is something that's so
small every place I can't see
it except at one point where
it's so big I can't see it.
In other words, I
can't see it at.
Well, accept some informality
with the unit impulse function
in the continuous time case, and
generally, we'll see that
we won't get into particular
difficulty.
OK, now the impulse is the
derivative of the step.
We saw in the discrete-time case
that the step could be
recovered from the impulse
through a running sum.
In continuous time, if the
impulse is the derivative of a
step, we would more or less
reasonably expect that the
step would be like an integral
of the impulse.
And indeed, that's true.
In fact, mathematically the
relationship is that the unit
step function in continuous time
is the running integral
of the unit impulse function.
And so it's the integral from
minus infinity up to time t,
where t is the argument at which
we're examining u(t).
And so, just as with the
discrete-time case, if we are
looking at t less than 0,
there's no area accumulated in
the integral.
If we're looking at t greater
than 0, then we accumulate the
area under the impulse.
OK, now we'll shortly be
returning to a further
discussion on use of impulses
and step functions.
And in particular, what we'll
see is that they provide a
very convenient and powerful
mechanism for describing a
particular class of systems
referred to as linear
time-invariant systems.
To lead up to that discussion,
which will be the principal
focus of the next lecture, let's
for the remainder of
this lecture talk about systems
in general and then
some properties of systems.
And as the lecture proceeds, the
specific properties that I
want to get to are properties
of linearity and time
invariance.
So let's first talk about
systems in general.
And a system in general, in its
most general definition,
is simply a transformation from
an input signal to an
output signal.
So in a continuous-time
case, we would have a
continuous-time system,
the input, x[t],
and the output, y[t].
And the box, in essence,
is used to denote a
transformation from x[t]
to y[t].
And sometimes, we'll also use a
shorthand notation along the
lines of indicating that the
input, x[t], is transformed to
the output, y[t].
Now, we have exactly the same
kind of definition in the
discrete-time case.
In the discrete-time case,
of course, the inputs are
sequences, and the outputs
are sequences.
And our shorthand notation
is similar.
Often when we talk about
systems, we'll want to talk
about interconnections
of systems.
And we'll see again in later
lectures that interconnections
become very important
and powerful.
And in the way of introducing
terminology, let me introduce
the terminology for a few
basic and important
interconnections of systems.
The first is what's referred to
as a cascade of systems, or
sometimes as a series
interconnection of systems.
And putting two systems in
cascade, as I've indicated
here, means taking the output
of one system--
let's say system 1--
and using that as the input to
the second system, which I've
denoted as system 2.
So in this cascade with system
1 first and system 2 second,
we have the output of system
1 going into the
input of system 2.
Now, we could, of course, take
those two systems and cascade
them in the reverse order.
Namely, take the output of
system 2 and put it into the
input of system 1.
And I've indicated that here.
And we have system 2 first
in the cascade
followed by system 1.
It's important to keep in mind
that in general, for general
systems, the order in which
you cascade the systems is
very important.
And in fact, the overall system
transformation will be
different depending on which
system came first and which
system came second.
For example, if system 1 was,
let's say, a system for which
the output doubles the input,
and system 2, the output is
the square root of the input,
clearly doubling first and
then taking the square root is
different than taking the
square root first and
then doubling.
Now, kind of amazingly, what
we'll see again when we get to
this issue of linearity
and time invariance--
which are a class of systems
that we'll focus in on--
somewhat amazingly, it turns
out that for that specific
class of systems, the overall
system transformation is
independent of the
order in which
the systems are cascaded.
And we'll see that, of course,
in more detail later on.
All right, well, that's
a cascade or a series
interconnection.
Let's look at another
interconnection, which is a
parallel interconnection
of systems.
And here, what's meant by the
interconnection is that the
input is fed simultaneously
into system 1
and into system 2.
And then, the outputs of these
two systems are added to give
the overall system output.
Now, in this particular case,
in contrast to a cascade, no
matter what the systems are, it
turns out that a parallel
combination, the order
in which they're
put in parallel is--
the overall transformation is
independent of the order.
And of course, that follows
from the fact that we're
simply adding up outputs.
And the outputs can be added
in any order because of the
fact that addition doesn't care
in which order you're
adding things up.
OK, so that's the parallel
interconnection.
And let's look at one more
interconnection, which is
what's referred to as a feedback
interconnection.
And this, again, is an
interconnection that will
become a very important topic
much later in the course.
But let me just indicate at this
point what I mean by it.
What a feedback interconnection
means is that
we have one system, system 1,
with an input and an output.
The output of system 1 is the
output of the overall system.
And that output is fed
into system 2.
The output of system 2 is then
added to the input to the
overall system.
So in essence, what happens in
a feedback interconnection is
we have one system.
The output of that system is
fed back through system 2,
added to the overall input.
And then, that sum is what forms
the input of system 1.
And we'll see that there are
lots of uses for feedback and,
of course, also lots of ways
that feedback gets in the way.
In fact, probably some of you
are already familiar with some
of the issues in feedback--
for example, in audio
systems or whatever.
But this will be a topic that
we'll devote a considerable
amount of time to later
in the course.
And then, of course, there are
lots of other interconnections
of systems.
And as the course progresses,
we'll see lots of ways in
which systems get interconnected
both in series
and in parallel and feedback
interconnections, et cetera,
to achieve a wide variety
of things.
Now, what I've said so far
relates to systems in general.
And you can't say much about
systems when you try to treat
them in their most
general form.
So it's useful and important to
focus in on properties that
a system may or may not have.
So what I'd like to do now is
turn our attention to system
properties.
And we'll define a
number of them.
Some of them, we'll want
to impose on a system.
Some of them, we may not want
But as things progress, we'll
tend to find it useful to ask
whether a system
does or doesn't
have a certain property.
Well, let's begin with a
property which I refer to here
as memoryless.
And what I mean by a system
being memoryless is that the
output at any given time, t_0,
depends only on the input at
the same time.
And so what I'm suggesting is
that a memoryless system is
one for which the output at a
specific time depends only on
the input at that time.
And that statement is true, or
that definition applies, both
for continuous time, as I've
indicated here, and also for
discrete time, as I've
indicated here.
And so we have a similar
definition in discrete time,
that the system is memoryless
if the output at any given
time depends only on the
input at that time.
Well, I have a number
of examples here.
Let's look at the first example
in which the output is
the square of the input.
And that is a possible system
either in continuous time or
discrete time.
And that system, as you would
expect, is commonly referred
to a squarer.
And since the square of a signal
at any time depends
only on the value of the signal
at that time, clearly a
squarer is a memoryless
system.
So in fact, we can indicate
here that this system is
memoryless.
Another important system is
what is referred to as an
integrator.
The output is equal to the
integral of the input.
Here, as I've indicated it,
it's not just integrating
x(t), but it's integrating
the square of x(t).
And whether we square before
we integrate or not, the
essential point is that since
we're integrating the input,
the value of the output at any
time is an accumulation of
past history of the input.
Well, an accumulation
of past history in
essence implies memory.
To get the output at a given
time requires the input over
an interval, specifically for
longer than that time.
So this system, in fact,
is not memoryless.
And now, I have a third
system defined here.
The third system is a system,
a discrete-time system, in
which the output is equal to
the input but not quite.
The output at some time--
let's say for
example at n = 0--
is equal to the input at one
time sample, or instant, or
value of the index
before that.
And so this, in fact, is a
system for which the output is
simply the input delayed or
shifted by one sample.
So this system is referred
to as a unit delay.
And now, the question is, is
that system memoryless?
Well, the output depends
only on the input--
the output at any instant
depends only on the input at
one instant.
But since it depends on an
instant prior to the time at
which we're looking, or
different than the time at
which we're looking, it violates
the definition of
memoryless that we introduced.
And so, in fact, the unit delay
is a system that has
memory, and so let's
indicate that here.
So this is not a memoryless
system because of the fact
that there is 1 unit of delay.
And in essence, delay
requires memory.
OK, so that's the issue of
memory and memoryless systems.
Let's now turn to another
property which a system may or
may not have, the property
referred to as invertibility.
Now, essentially what
invertibility means is that
given the output of the system,
you can figure out
uniquely what the input was.
That's one definition
for invertibility.
Said another way, invertibility
means that given
the output, there's only
one input that
could have caused it.
That's another common definition
for invertibility.
Another way of looking at it is,
in fact, to look at it in
the context of a cascade
of systems.
So let's consider a system.
And here is a system which I
refer to as system A. And this
could be continuous-time
or discrete-time.
It has an input, x_1(t) or
x_1[n], depending on whether
it's continuous-time or
discrete-time that we're
talking about, and an
associated output.
And here, we have system
B with its
associated input and output.
And now, let's put these
two systems in cascade.
So we'll take the output of
system 1 and feed it into the
input of system 2--
or system B. So the output of
system A goes into the input
of system B. And if system A is
invertible and system B is
its inverse, then the
consequence is that the output
of system B is equal to
the input of system A.
Now, I know there are a lot
of inputs and outputs and
inverses in there.
But essentially, what we mean by
what I've just said is that
if we have system A and it's
invertible, and if we cascade
it with its inverse, system B,
then the overall cascade of
these two systems is simply
what's referred to as the
identity system.
And the identity system is
simply a system which if you
put a signal into it, you get
the same signal out of it.
In other words, the overall
system is no
transformation at all.
And clearly, of course, for
a system to be able to be
cascaded with another system
to generate the identity
system requires that the first
system, system A, be
invertible.
So let's look at
some examples.
If we had system A as I've
indicated here, where now the
output is the running integral
of the input--
and remember that we saw the
running integral when we
talked about the relationship
between steps and impulses--
if this happened to be
an impulse, then the
output would be a step.
This system is referred to, of
course, as an integrator since
the output is the running
integral of the input.
And the integrator, in fact,
is an invertible system.
And its inverse is a system for
which the output is the
derivative of the input.
So the inverse of system A, if
system A is an integrator, is
a system for which the output is
equal to the derivative of
the input which, not
surprisingly, is referred to
as a differentiator.
So an integrator
is invertible.
Its inverse is a
differentiator.
What you might want to think
about is the question of
whether a differentiator
is invertible.
Now, to answer that, what you
would ask yourself is, if you
always knew what the derivative
of the signal is,
would you necessarily know
what the signal was?
In other words, if you have a
differentiator and you have
the output of the
differentiator, could you
always figure out what
the input was?
If you could, the system
would be invertible.
If you couldn't, the system
would not be invertible.
So you might just want
to think about that.
I guess I won't tell
you right now.
But I'm sure that you'll think
about that more, particularly
with the guidance of
the video manual.
OK, well let's look at
one last system.
I've indicated here a system
for which the output is
related to the input
through this curve.
And what I mean by this curve,
which wasn't done quite as
well as I might have, is that
the output is equal to the
square of the input.
So this system is our squarer
as we talked about before.
We saw previously, or discussed
the fact previously,
that the squarer is a
memoryless system.
And now the question is, is a
squarer an invertible system?
Well, the question then is, if
you're given the square of a
signal, can you figure out
what the signal is?
And as I'm sure you've already
suspected, the answer to that
is no, because obviously if
the signal was negative or
positive, you wouldn't be able
to figure that out after
you've squared.
So in fact, the squarer
is not invertible.
All right, so we've introduced
several properties.
And by the way, as we've gone
through it, also introduced
some systems that will
turn out to be useful
and important systems.
And now, let's continue with
some other properties.
A property that we'll find
useful to make reference to,
from time to time, and will,
in fact, play a fairly
important role in a variety of
discussions during the course,
is a property which is referred
to as causality.
Now, in essence what causality
means is the following.
A system is set to be causal if,
as one way of saying it,
it only responds when
you kick it.
Is another way of saying it, its
response at any time only
depends on values of the input
prior to that time.
So a causal system, both
continuous time and discrete
time, is defined sometimes
as a system which has the
property that the output at any
time depends only on the
input prior or equal
to that time.
Essentially what we're saying
is that the system can't
anticipate future inputs.
And so that, in fact, is another
possible definition
for causality, that the system
is causal if it can't
anticipate future inputs.
Finally, an alternative
way of saying it
mathematically is as follows.
If I have two signals, x_1(t)
and x_2(t), with their
associated outputs, y_1(t) and
y_2(t), then a system is said
to be causal if and only if it
has the property that if those
two inputs are identical up
until some time, then the
outputs are identical up
until the same time.
So if we have two signals that
are exactly the same up until
some time and perhaps do
something different later on,
causality requires that the
outputs not anticipate the
fact that those inputs are at
some future time going to do
something different.
And that, in fact, is the most
useful mathematical definition
of causality.
And of course, I've written that
here for continuous time.
And the same definition of
causality also applies for
discrete time.
OK, well let's look
at an example.
Let's take an example which
is a system which is the
following discrete-time
system.
The output at any given time
is the sum of x[n], x[n]
delayed, and x[n]
anticipated.
And this is, in fact, a system
that's very useful and
referred to as a
moving average.
And so if we think of a moving
average, if we have here a
sequence, x[n]
and x[n]
with other values going off in
both directions, for any
value, n_0, at which we're
computing the output--
and this is y[n], the output--
we take x[n 0], x[n 0-1],
and x[n 0+1].
And so to form that moving
average, we would take these
three values and combine them
together, adding them and then
dividing by 3 to get that.
Well, is the system causal?
One way to answer that is to
determine whether the output
at any given time depends on
future values of the input.
And clearly, if you look at
this, what you see is that the
output at time n_0 depends both
on past values and on
future values.
As opposed to another moving
average, which I've indicated
here, where I simply
shifted the values
that I combined together.
And in this case, because of the
way in which I picked the
values, the output depends on
the value at n_0, the value at
n_0 - 1, and the value
at n_0 - 2.
So y[n 0]
would depend here on x[n 0],
x[n 0-1], and x[n 0-2].
And so in this case, the
system is not causal.
And in this case, the
system is causal.
All right, now let's turn to
another system property, the
property referred
to as stability.
Now, there are lots of
definitions of stability, and
some of them get very
mathematical and formal.
But we've chosen, and what we'll
use as our definition of
stability, is what's called
bounded-input
bounded-output stability.
And essentially, the definition
is that a system is
stable if and only if for
every bounded input, the
output is bounded.
So the notion is if you have a
system and the input never
gets above some finite value,
then stability requires that
the output also stay within
some bounded values.
And I'm sure that stability
and instability are things
that you're kind of informally
familiar with.
Let me just emphasize the point
with something that I
borrowed actually from
my son with some
reluctance on his part.
If we, for example, take a
system like this, which is in
essence a pendulum, this system
as I'm holding it here
is stable because if I put in
a bounded input, which is a
displacement, the output, which
is the movement of it,
remains bounded.
Now on the other hand, if I
put the system like this,
which is, in fact, what's
referred to as an inverted
pendulum, although we could
conceivably get this to
balance, just a slight
displacement because of the
fact that the pendulum
is inverted, a slight
displacement and the output
becomes unbounded.
Now, an interesting thing with
the inverted pendulum, by the
way, which I'm sure all of you,
if you were anything like
me, were intrigued with as a
kid, was the notion that you
could take an inverted pendulum
and in effect turn it
back into a stable system by
using what I'm doing right
now, which is feedback.
What I've done in that case is
I've stabilized the system by
using feedback, visual
feedback, from
my eye to my hand.
And in fact, one of the very
important things that we'll
see about feedback when we talk
about feedback systems
much later in the course is
that one of their very
important applications is in
stabilizing unstable systems.
By the way, one of their
problems is that if not used
correctly, it can destabilize
stable systems.
OK, well let's continue on with
our property of stability.
I have here, again, the example
of an integrator.
And as I indicate here, if we
have an integrator and we put
a step function into it or a
step signal into it, the
output is what's referred
to as a ramp signal.
It linearly increases.
Now, the question is,
is a ramp unbounded?
The input is bounded.
The step input is bounded.
The ramp is unbounded because
if you try to establish any
bound on it, you can always go
out far enough in time so that
the output will exceed
that bound.
So in fact, the integrator
is not stable.
OK, now finally, I'd like to
turn to two properties that
we'll make considerable use of
as the course goes on, the
properties of time invariance
and linearity.
Time invariance, in essence,
says that the system doesn't
really care what you
call the origin.
In other words, it says if you
take the input and you shift
it in time, all that you've done
is taken the output and
shifted it in time by
the same amount.
Somewhat more formally as I've
indicated here, if in
continuous time we have an
input, x(t), which generate an
output, y(t), then time
invariance requires that if
the input is shifted by any
amount of time, the output is
shifted by the same
amount of time.
And exactly the same applies
in discrete time.
For example, if we have a system
which is a system I've
shown here, which by the way is
the system that we talked
about previously to go from
a step sequence--
I'm sorry, from an impulse
sequence to a step sequence.
We called it a running sum.
And actually, what it's also
often called is an
accumulator.
What it does is accumulate
past values of the input.
Well, is the accumulator
time-invariant?
The best way to establish that
is to work through the
equations and verify that it
either does or doesn't satisfy
the formal definition
of time invariance.
Informally, if you think about
it, it makes intuitive sense
that the accumulator is
time-invariant because if
you're accumulating values and
if you delay the values that
you're putting into the
accumulator, then the
associated values that come
out will be delayed by the
same amount.
The accumulator doesn't care
really if you shift the input.
It'll just simply shift
the associated output.
But more generally, if you're
trying to test time
invariance, it's important to
return to the definition.
And that's what you're required
to do in the examples
in the video manual.
OK, well, I indicate
another example.
We had the example of
an accumulator.
Here's another example which, in
fact, as we'll see later is
a system which is a modulator.
The output is the input,
modulated.
And although you might think at
first that this system is
time invariant, in fact it is
not, because the input shifted
generates an output which is
the input shifted times the
same modulation function.
Whereas if we were to take the
output of the system, we have
x(t) is the input, then what
that would correspond to is
sin(t-t_0) * x(t-t_0).
And since these two are
not equal, this
system is not time invariant.
And this is an example that
often causes a slight amount
of difficulty because it seems
like when you look
at it ought to be.
And so I strongly encourage you,
in the context of working
problems in the manual, that you
think very carefully about
this and at least believe
that what I told you
is the right answer.
OK, now the final property that
I want to introduce today
is the property of linearity.
And linearity is defined in a
manner similar for continuous
time and discrete time.
And what it says is that if
we have some inputs with
associated outputs, let's say
x_1(t) and x_2(t), then a
system is linear if it has the
property that the output to a
linear combination of those
inputs is the same linear
combination of the associated
outputs.
And so that's what I've
indicated here, that if we now
put into the system a linear
combination of those inputs,
then for linearity, we require
that the output is the same
linear combination.
And exactly the same applies
in discrete time.
And you can show from this
definition that if a system is
linear with two inputs, then
it's linear in terms of an
arbitrary number of inputs.
I have a number of examples.
And these are examples that,
again, I ask you to think
about as you look at
the video manual.
Just to suggest the answer--
well, not to suggest but to
tell you the answer, the
integrator as we have
here is linear.
This system in which the output
is double the input
plus a constant, you would
kind of think it's linear
because it's a straight line.
But one has to be careful.
And in fact, as it turns out,
this is not linear.
There is a qualifier attached
to it because it has a
property referred to as
incrementally linear, which is
discussed somewhat
more in the text.
And finally, we have a system
which is the squarer that I've
indicated again here.
And squaring it is definitely
not a linear operation.
OK, so what we've done, then,
is to introduce a number of
properties of systems.
And we've also, by the way, as
I've stressed previously, as
we've gone along introduced also
a number of important and
useful systems, like the
accumulator, the integrator,
the differentiator, et cetera.
What we'll see is that the
properties of linearity and
time invariance in particular
become central and important
properties.
And in the next lecture, what
we'll show is that with
systems that are linear and
time-invariant, the use of the
impulse function, both in
continuous time and discrete
time, provides an
extraordinarily important and
useful mechanism for
characterizing those systems.
Thank you.